hello and thank you for joining us for
today's
presentation part of our agilent cell
analysis global conference
my name is yama abbasi and i'm
head of business and application
development within cell analysis
division
at agilent before i introduce our
speakers
for today allow me to share a bit about
agilent and our products for
cell analysis agilent
is a trusted leader in life sciences
clinical research diagnostics and
applied chemical markets providing
laboratories with instruments services
consumables applications and expertise
to enable
our customers to gain the insights they
seek
ac is one of the newest addition to
agilent cell analysis division which
includes seahorse luxel
and also biotech which was recently
acquired by
agilent
agilent's rapidly growing cell analysis
portfolio
enables deeper more reliable insights
across a variety of cell analysis
applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand
complex cellular environments and
interactions
including sulfate fitness and function
our comprehensive cell analysis
tools are critically important in
various investigative fields such as
cancer
inflammation immunology immune oncology
and as you'll find out today for
virology
and also cardiotoxicity as well
in this session we have the privilege of
having two speakers from agilent cell
analysis division
dr brandon lamarche followed by dr
xiaoyu zhang brandon lamarche received
his phd in chemistry from ohio state
university
where his research focused on the
chemistry and enzymology of dna damage
and repair
seeking to understand the ways in which
organisms strike a balance between
these two opposing processes to maintain
their
fitness fuel their evolution and defend
themselves against pathogens
he subsequently worked as a postdoctoral
fellow at the salk institute where he
studied the biochemistry
of dna double-stranded break repair
with particular emphasis on the types of
dsbs generated by cancer
chemotherapeutics
he now works as a principal scientist at
agilent technologies where he focuses on
developing real-time cell analysis
applications using accelerance platform
currently his two primary fields of
interest are cancer immunotherapy
and infectious disease
our second speaker dr xiaoyu zhang
attained her phd
in molecular and developmental biology
from the university of california at
riverside and received post-doctoral
training
at sanford burnham uh medical discovery
institute
dr zhang is currently the senior
research scientist at agilent
technology specializing in the
development of applications
for excellence real-time cell analysis
cardio-related instruments
leading cardiac safety screening
programs and providing
technical support for rtca cardio
related systems
before i hand over uh the presentation
to brandon and jaryu there are a couple
of housekeeping notes
there'll be a question and answer period
immediately following the talk
and to help us get as many of your
questions as possible we encourage you
to type your questions during the
presentation
also our speakers will be joining the
networking lounge
after the talk and if you have further
questions please follow the link to the
ver to this
virtual lounge and with that i will hand
over
the presentation to brandon and then
followed by xiaoyu
thank you yama so today i'm going to be
talking about antiviral drug screening
and characterization using the
accelegence rtca
esight instrument i'll start off by
introducing the site directly this is
the newest addition
to the accelergence line of instruments
eside is the only instrument in the
world
that interrogates cell health and
behavior in real time
using cellular impedance while
simultaneously acquiring live cell
images
once i've described these two
functionalities i'll then move to
a section where i focus on e-site
example data
and i'll do this in three different
parts first i'll look at
tracking viral cytopathic effects using
this
combination of impedance plus imaging in
the second part
i'll look at applying the assay in the
context of antiviral drug research
we'll look at a screening step where
you're simply trying to determine which
drugs within a library
have any antiviral activity and then
i'll move to a characterization
step where we take hits from the library
and
characterize them in more detail using
ic or ec50 values
to help explain how esight measures
cellular impedance
i'm showing here one of the specialized
plates that the instrument uses
they look like regular micro tighter
plates but the difference is that
they're electronic
so if you look at the underside of the
plate you'll see that there's a gold
biosensor array that's integrated into
all 96 well bottoms to understand what
the biosensors are doing
i'm zoomed in here on a single well from
one of these plates
e site provides very weak electric
potential to the bottom of the plate
and this causes electric current to flow
from one biosensor to the next
if cells happen to be present they act
as insulators
meaning they resist the flow of that
electric current
another word for that resistance is
impedance
now as eastside applies a constant
potential
the amount of current that flows through
the system is dependent upon
the number of cells that are present in
the well bottom the morphology of those
cells whether they're big or small
and also how tightly those cells are
bound to the bottom of the well
it turns out that this impedance
approach is an extremely sensitive
method for virology assays
because a canonical viral cytopathic
effect
includes changes in all three of these
properties
so in a typical impedance assay for
virology
we start off with an intermediate or
high confluence
for ourselves and when virus is added
and the cells begin to display a
cytopathic effect they start rounding
attaching to the plate bottom less
tightly this allows for more current to
flow through the system
and as that cytopathic effect becomes
more severe and cells lyse are detached
from the cell bottom
even more current is capable of flowing
through the system
the take home message is this impedance
allows for you to track
the full continuum of the cytopathic
effect in real time
and to do so in a manner that's entirely
non-invasive
so in the context of antiviral drug
assays
what we're asking is simply does the
inclusion of drug
stop or slow this progression
now the cartoon i just showed you is
very much a simplification
the biosensors are actually designed in
an interdigitated array
like this photo is showing you can see
that the
biosensors take up about 75 to the well
bottom
and there's a central region of the well
which is available for microscopy
over the last 16 years what we've seen
with the traditional accelerance
instruments is that
most users are employing impedance as
their primary readout
and they're then using images for
confirmation
and so what that typical workflow looks
like is that
you acquire impedance continuously and
then at key time points remove the plate
take it to a microscope to acquire
images and then bring the plate back to
the accelergence instrument
for continuous impedance monitoring
while that works the motivation behind
development of the new accelergence
instrument the esight
was that we would be able to do
impedance monitoring
but also couple that with live cell
imaging and do it all in a single
instrument
so the idea here is that you're getting
impedance and images
all from the same well at the same time
there's zero hands on time once the
assay is started
so you never have to do any sort of
endpoint processing
and esight provides bright field images
in addition to
red green and blue fluorescence images
the workflow for esight is very flexible
i'm showing one variation of it here
that involves seeding cells into the
specialized plate
putting the plate into the e-site which
is housed inside a regular tissue
culture incubator
and allowing for those cells to attach
and proliferate
over the first day at that point the
plate can be removed
and virus can be added in the presence
or absence of drug
and you're now ready to simultaneously
monitor the two outputs
so using the microscopy viewing window
you're going to get your bright field
plus red green and blue fluorescence
images
and using the biosensor array
you're going to get the impedance data
so we've seen what the instrument is and
what its outputs are
and let's look now at tracking a
cytopathic
effect using both of these outputs
so the model system is adenovirus 5
infecting heck 293 cells
if this is all we used we would be able
to acquire bright field images which are
quite useful
but in order to make the assay more
information rich
we can get orthogonal perspectives on
the cytopathic effect by using
fluorophores so we're using an
adenovirus that expresses gfp
constitutively
behind the cmv promoter and we've
engineered the
hex cells to express red fluorescent
protein
that's localized to their nuclei
so one of the first things that we're
interested in is determining what the
optimal virus dosing is
uh for our drug screening and
characterization assays
uh here we seeded 10 000 cells per well
and 20 hours later we infected the cells
with virus that had been 5x serially
diluted
this is the impedance signal represented
by a parameter called cell index and
we're looking at that as a function of
time
this first data is for the uninfected
sample
impedance was acquired once every 15
minutes so there are 480 data points
here
and one of the benefits of acquiring at
such high temporal frequency
is that it gives information about cell
health and behavior
that you wouldn't get if you were
sampling you know once every few hours
so here in this initial phase this
represents the
adhesion of cells to the well bottom
subsequently we see a proliferation
phase
there's a small blip here this
represents the time point when this
plate was removed from the instrument
in order to add virus not to this well
but to other wells in the plate
we see that the impedance signal
eventually plateaus and the reason for
that is that the cells have reached 100
confluence at this point
it's worth pointing out that in this
real-time format
all of this data is acquired from a
single well so it's very different than
an endpoint assay where each well gives
you a single data point
so what does this look like when we
infect the cells with virus
i'll move from very low concentrations
to high concentrations of the virus
so initially we don't really see much
impact on impedance at all
by the time we get to about a 9 million
fold dilution of the virus we're
beginning to see a cytopathic effect
reflected by this drop in impedance and
that becomes more severe
as the virus concentration is increased
so very clearly there's a dose
dependency to this
i'm representing here this as virus
dilution factor but we can also
represent it by the moi
ultimately what we decided was that we
would work with a very
sort of common moi for a screening or
characterization assay and that's that
we would
work at an moi of one represented here
by this aqua trace
in this next slide i'm going to zoom in
to that condition
and what i'd like to address is the
issue of
what this impedance data actually
reflects so if you're not used to it
you might ask how do i know that this
actually corresponds to a legitimate
cytopathic effect
and this is where the imaging
capabilities of esight are very useful
while that impedance data was being
acquired cells in the microscopy viewing
window
were being used to collect images and so
we can now juxtapose these two different
types of data
at two hours uh the cells are still very
rounded and have
have not yet attached by 10 hours cells
are beginning to attach
and spread out by 25 hours we see that
the cells are fully attached and have
proliferated
by 50 hours the cells are totally
confluent and have packed in very
tightly next to one another
by 70 hours we're beginning to see a
cytopathic effect
this 70 hour time point here corresponds
to
50 hours post virus edition
and then as we go out to 120 hours we
see the cytopathic effect is even more
severe
with cell death rounding and detachment
so very clearly there's strong
correlation between the impedance signal
and what's physically taking place with
the cells
now if we're using bright field alone
this is certainly very helpful
but again if we include the fluorescence
channels
it gives us a different perspective on
what's going on and so it allows for us
to transition from this to this
we see the cell nuclei in red and the
virus encoded gfp
obviously here in green increasing in
intensity over time
so the benefit is that we don't just get
prettier pictures but we can also
pull quantitative information out of
those images
if we're using brightfield alone we can
track
changes in percent confluence over time
but now with the the red nuclei we can
count the number of cells that are
present over time
and with the green signal we can do
things like count
the number of cells that are infected or
if we quantify the intensity of the
green signal
we can literally watch the replication
of the virus
this allows for us to juxtapose
different types of information in the
plot like the one shown here
here again in black we see the killing
response in by impedance
and its inverse correlation with the
signal for the virus encoded gfp
shown here this just gives a general
overview of what it looks like to track
viral cytopathic effects using both of
these types of output
and we'll move now to applying this in
the context of antiviral drugs
in a screening phase so the format
here we switch from using red cells to
blue cells and we also change the
seeding density down to 6 000 cells per
well
here 24 hours after seeding we added a
mixture containing adenovirus at an moi
of one
along with antiviral drug at 50
micromolar
now in some cases the concentration or
excuse me the solubility of the drug
limited us and we were not able to
obtain a 50 micromolar concentration
today i'm going to just show you five
compounds
the first three of these sedophobia bryn
sodofovir and again
cyclovir each inhibit the adenovirus dna
polymerase
the fourth compound ribovirin this
mechanism of action isn't fully
understood
and the fifth compound stabudine is an
inhibitor of the hiv reverse
transcriptase and we're using that here
as a negative control
so here again we're going to look at the
impedance signal
and in terms of timing we're not going
to look at
the initial 24 hours of cell adhesion
and proliferation
so here t equals zero represents the
moment at which virus
and drug were added if we look at cells
by themselves they proliferate over this
80 hour window
when we add in virus it takes about a
day but eventually there's a very severe
cytopathic effect
when we include the negative control
stabidine you can see
that it has minimal impact on impedance
the same is also true of ribovirin
but with ganciclovir sedophovir and bryn
sodofovir
you see a pretty dramatic shifting in
the impedance signal
this is an example of a gain of signal
format
where the virus is causing loss of
signal
and if you have a positive hit that drug
is causing a gain in signal to look more
like the cell alone control
this is important because when you have
a gain of signal assay
a positive hit is consistent with the
drug being effective against the virus
and that drug not being toxic to the
cells
so if bryn sudophovir was toxic we would
see the impedance signal dropping
not increasing
the data is pretty clear in its current
format but we can represent it in a few
different ways
one of them would be to calculate the
area under these curves
as i'm showing here
and this just helps to demonstrate that
indeed impedance is very efficient for
being able to
rank order drug efficacy and determine
you know what is or is not a hit
for screening an important question is
whether
these impedance data are an accurate
reflection of what's physically taking
place with the cells
and this is where we can make use again
of the
imaging capabilities of the instrument
so
without infection by virus we see the
cells are proliferated they're highly
confluent
when virus is present there's a severe
cytopathic effect and we see
a whole lot of that virus-encoded gfp
present
the first three or four drugs don't
really have a whole lot of impact on
what we're seeing in terms of morphology
or the gfp signal
but cedophovir and bryn sodofovir
obviously suppress
the viral cpe pretty dramatically
so the answer to this question is yes
indeed there's strong correlation
between the impedance and the imaging
readouts
on the basis of this data we decided to
study brynn cedopovir in further detail
in order to determine its ec 50 value
now before i
i show you those assays i want to
address the issue of assay quality
like how effective is this assay for
being able to detect hits that have
activity against adenovirus when you
think about the ideal assay
it really should have a large signal
there should be low variation in that
signal
there should be low background and there
should also be low variation in the
background signal
people have developed a number of
different ways in order to quantify
the quality of a screening assay and one
of them that has gained favor in the
last 20 years
is this z prime factor
this equation uh takes into account the
standard deviation for both
positive and negative controls as well
as the mean value
for positive and negative controls the
take home here is that
when z prime is larger than 0.4 an assay
is considered to be acceptable
or an effective tool for screening if
that value is larger than 0.5 it's
considered to be excellent
we wanted to calculate the z prime
factor for the eastside assay i've shown
you
and to do so we took half of the wells
in a plate
and added cells plus virus plus negative
control
dmso when we plot all 48 of those
data traces at the same time we can see
that here
so again over the first day the cells
are proliferating
and then a very massive cytopathic
effect takes place
in the other half of the plate we had
cells that were infected with virus in
the presence of our positive control
which in this case is bryn sedophivir
when we plot all 48 of those traces
together
we see the data shown here in gray so
again there's this uh suppression of the
cytopathic effect it takes a lot longer
for this impedance signal to start
dropping down towards zero
than when no drug is present we can take
these data and
and put them into the z prime equation
here i'm going to plot the z prime value
over time reminder uh yellow represents
the acceptable range
and the orange represents the excellent
range for the z prime value
this is the data so we can see very
clearly
that esight is providing or acting as an
excellent tool
for the purposes of screening now notice
that
the z prime score becomes excellent
right around 40 hours
here at 40 hours is when the positive
and negative
data sets begin to separate out from one
another and in other words this is the
time point where we can begin to have a
lot of confidence
in the ability of this assay to
differentiate between what is and is not
a hit
you'll notice that the z prime score is
maximal or optimal at 60 hours
and that makes perfect sense because
this is the time point where
there's maximal separation between these
two data sets
and you'll also notice that the z prime
score begins to decrease over time
and this again makes sense because here
the
positive control is decreasing in value
and is becoming more and more
similar to the negative control and that
convergence of those two data sets means
that out here at this time regime
it's a less effective tool for telling
you what is or is not a hit
this ability to analyze z prime as a
function of time
is extremely powerful you could
calculate z prime using an endpoint
assay
for example at 100 hours and you'd be
able to tell that you're getting
an excellent score and therefore it's a
good tool but what you wouldn't know
from an endpoint assay
is that by going to 60 hours
the tool becomes even more excellent
it's power
capacity for determining what is or is
not a hit is even better at 60 hours
than it is at 100
and so having this real-time data allows
for you to make those distinctions
now we can do the same type of z-prime
calculation
using rather than this impedance data
the virus-encoded gfp data and that's
being shown here
two things to note the curve shape is
you know largely similar
but the z prime score from impedance is
always larger or better than or more
excellent than
that determined based on imaging and the
other thing to note
is the window over which the z prime
score remains
excellent it's always well it is
larger when you're using impedance than
it is when you're using the image based
readout
so for impedance it remains excellent
between 40 and 100 hours
whereas for the imaging readout it
remains excellent between 40 and roughly
70 hours
i don't have time to discuss that now
but i would be happy to
address that during the question and
answer period if anyone's interested
so we'll move now uh to actually
characterizing bryn sodofovir
trying to determine its ec 50 value so
the assay format
remains the same uh the difference is
that we're now going to vary the renzo
fever concentration between eight and
one thousand nanomolar
this is what cells alone look like this
is cells plus virus
and then adding in brain cedifier from
low
to intermediate to high concentrations
how do we take this data and determine
an ec50 value
well again we can make use of the area
under the curve
and i'm showing that here area under the
curve based on the impedance readout
as a function of the log of the drug
concentration
so you see this gives us a canonical
sigmoidal dose response curve
the r squared is excellent and it
suggests that ec50 value is around 265
nanomolar
it's worth pointing out that ideally we
would like to have some additional data
points to represent this upper asymptote
the problem here is that we're limited
by the solubility of bryn sadofovir
for this particular assays conditions we
just really couldn't get the drug
concentration higher
than thousand nanomolar
so everything i just showed you is based
on impedance but we can do the same type
of analysis
using imaging readouts
so as we go from no drug to low drug to
intermediate drug
to high concentrations of the drug there
is a very clear
knock down of that viral cpe
and we can use the site software to
quantify this
so here we ask the software to encircle
all green
cells and then we asked it to quantify
the intensity of that green signal
on a per cell basis so i'm plotting that
green signal here
as a function of time when cells are
treated with virus alone you see a
steady increase in the gfp signal
around 60 hours the signal starts
dropping and the reason for that is that
the cells are lysing
as we add in drug we see a reduction
in this gfp signal as you would expect
now this is an example of an assay
format where there's loss of signal
and it's important to note that there's
an inherent ambiguity when you try and
interpret loss of signal data
very clearly when we go from no drug to
drug there's a reduction in the amount
of gfp that's there
but we don't immediately know how to
interpret this one explanation is that
bryn cedovir is indeed inhibiting the
virus
but alternatively it may be the case
that brynsodophivir
is actually inhibiting some of the host
cell machinery
for example if brynsophivir inhibits the
host cell ribosome
then that would suppress the ability to
translate the virus
gfp's mrna
so importantly because the impedance
output
is a gain of signal it helps eliminate
the ambiguity associated with this loss
of signal
that's one of the benefits of having
this sort of dual readout
in terms of data analysis we can again
look at this
using area under the curve here we see
the inverse curve shape
again the r squared is is quite nice and
this suggests the ec 50 is around 325
nanomolar
once again we would prefer to have
additional data points but
the solubility of the the drug won't
allow us to do that
when we compare the two outputs of
imaging impedance we see that
we have 265 versus 325 they differ by
just about 20 percent
which i consider to be excellent
correlation considering that this is a
cell-based assay
so with that i'd like to draw some
conclusions we've seen that
using real-time impedance monitoring we
get a very sensitive readout for viral
cytopathic effects
and this is being obtained through a
gain of signal assay format
we've seen that it functions as an
excellent screening tool
based on the z prime factor and we've
seen how we can use
impedance to determine ec 50 values for
drugs that are
successful hits from the screening phase
the live cell imaging provides a very
nice corroboration of the impedance data
today i really only have time to look at
the virus-encoded gfp signal
but we could have just as easily
incorporated analyses
that used the nuclear blue fluorescent
protein the percent confluence
or even included a red red fluorescent
protein
signal that we just didn't make use of
today
there's very good correlation between
the ec 50 values determined by the
impedance and imaging outputs
and one of the reasons for that is that
both are being acquired simultaneously
from the exact same population of cells
this is very different than traditional
assays where
you might try and run it using two
approaches but they have to be done in
different plates and in different
instruments
so if the values are so similar from
impedance and imaging what's the value
of having both
well if you remember you know as we all
know the gold standard in science is
that you get a result
and then you confirm that result using a
different orthogonal approach
unfortunately because of time and cost
we often don't do that
but with esight you get your primary
result
and your confirmation all within a
single assay
so you get at least twice the amount of
data and you don't have to double your
workflow
it's the same as setting up a single
assay
when we compare esight with traditional
methods like a plaque reduction assay or
a color metric assay
one of the things to point out is that
the ec50 values are very similar
between these approaches and so
as one example of that i'm showing here
an analysis of
acyclovir's ability to inhibit
herpes simplex different strains this
was done
using a plaque reduction assay side by
side with an excelligence impedance
assay
you can see that the ec 50 values from
these approaches
often are just two or three fold
different from one another it's a very
good correlation this is one example
out of you know many thousands of papers
that have been published over the last
16 years
showing good correlation between
impedance and traditional methods
another difference between esight and
traditional methods
is how simple the workflow is you simply
are adding cells
and virus and drug to the plate but
there's no additional processing or
handling of the plate beyond that
and then finally there's the benefit of
having the real time readout versus
traditional assays which tend to be
endpoint to highlight that
i'm showing here a plot of the virus
encoded gfp signal
as a function of time we see that for
cells plus
virus in blue versus cells plus virus
plus brin sedophobia and aqua
if you happen to be doing this assay in
an endpoint format and you chose
somewhere around 80 hours for your
analysis you would see that the two
types of data are very similar to each
other and you would conclude that this
drug is not effective
in contrast if you analyzed at around 50
or 60 hours
you would see big separation between the
two data sets and you would conclude
that the drug is indeed effective
this just highlights sort of the danger
of an endpoint assay
not being able to see the full continuum
really puts you at risk of drawing
spurious conclusions
finally having seen the the impedance
and eastside in particular
can be used for uh drug uh screening and
characterization
uh we're now gonna move uh on and my my
colleague xiaoyu is going to show us
how this technology can also be used for
evaluating
the safety of these compounds i'll be
happy to answer any questions at the end
of the talk
and for now i'll hand it over to show
you
thank you brandon in my talk i will
discuss the assessment of cardiac safety
of
antiviral drug using exogens
drug induced toxicity due to drug
attraction
among all these toxicities
cardiovascular toxicity is the major
concern
according to this pie chart the cv
toxicity
includes not only the drug induced
electro physiologically changes in the
heart
such as qt interval change and
arrhythmia but also the adverse
impact on contractility and the
structure
therefore an ideal in vitro system which
could provide
comprehensive cardiac safety profile of
drugs
would be able to evaluate cell responses
to them
from multiple angles
in order to meet this need x we
developed the accelerating rtc cardio
ucr system
and the system uses this 48 well plate
and the difference between cardio ecr
system and the rtc system
just mentioned by brandon is that the
cardio ecr system includes
not only the impedance electrodes to
merge the impedance signal
but the few potential electrodes to
measure electrical activity of the cells
and again the impedance electrodes are
for impedance measurement
and based on this impedance curve we can
evaluate
variability beside this information
cardio ecr system also can allow us to
measure contractility
and based on this contractile or
impedance waveform
we can calibrate the beating amplitude
beating rate
and the bearing rhythm can be evaluated
using this
parameter called beating rhythm
irregularity
and the field potential electrodes
measures the fuel potential signal
and this is the very typical fuel
potential signal you will get from the
system
and you are going to get two major
parameters here
the first one we call fp amplitude which
is the amplitude of this spike
and the other one is fuel potential
duration fpd
fpd is the surrogate for the qt interval
which is the ekg readout of our heart
and based on the changes in these two
parameters
we are can evaluate the ion channel
activities of the cell
and here i want to show you the typical
data collected from the cardiovcr system
and the first we are going to get this
time course of impedance readout and
fuel potential readout
the time scale here could be a couple
hours or 100 hours
so we call this low time resolution data
of cardio ecr system
and based on this impedance waveform we
can observe cell attachment
spreading right after cell seeding and
cell growth
afterwards and after we add compound
if we can see the reduction in overall
cell index
which suggests the cell death
and the time course of fp readout
doesn't really provide much
much valuable information however if you
zoom in
a data point on this curve then you will
get a high time resolution readout
and here shows the 30 seconds fuel
potential waveforms
and based on the impedance readout you
can get this contractile waveform
and each waveform represents one beat
and since cardiovcr system records
impedance readout and fuel potential
readout at the same time
the software can superimpose these two
signals
and show us the excitation contraction
coupling of cardiomyocytes
so in brandon's talk he used heck 293
cell line which is the kidney cell line
for the drug screening which is a
suitable
model for his study however for my
project
cardiac safety assessment i use this
human ipsc during cardiomyocytes
which has been widely used as more
physiologically
relevant cell model for this type of
study
in a typical experiment on the xero
we just see the cells directly into our
cardio ecr plate
and the plate will then engage in this
clay durator
and this plate reader is placed in the
incubator all the time
and the cell performance will be
monitored
right after the cell sitting and
before compound addition we will do this
cell status qc
the reason we are doing that we just
want to make sure the cells
can can generate very robust and
consistent
signals before compound addition so if
the cell passed qc
next day will add compound and
cell variability contractility and
electrophysiology will be evaluated
from the same cell population and
these are the antiviral drugs tested in
this study
no matter whether they are nucleotide
analogues or
chemical derivatives they inhibit virus
replication via the incubation of rna
polymerase
and the concentration we tested here
including the concentration
below at and above c-max except this
influenza drug due to the solubility
issue
the highest concentration for this drug
was 300 micromolar which is
is c-max
now let's look at the cardiac safety
profile of from the
severe first i want to focus on
the normalized cell index as brandon
discussed in his talk
the time course of normalized cell index
reflects the changes of cell
attachment and variability
at 0.5 micromolar ram densifier didn't
have much impact on cell
index curve compared to this dmso
control
however at 5 michael molar it started to
decrease
cell index at 40 hours which gradually
decreased by 60 after five days
treatment
as the concentration going up the
reduction of
cell index started earlier and showed
more profound effects
overall ram deserver reduced
cell attachment and variability in a
dose and time
dependent manner and the next
i would like to check contractile
activity after compound addition
so in order to do that i will zoom in
a data point on this curve
the traces here show 30 seconds
contraction
at 72 hours after compound addition
so compared to the dmso treated wells
the black trace here
the 0.5 micromolar didn't affect
contractility
demonstrated by these consistent and
robust waveforms
however at five micromolar we can detect
irregular beating rhythm and at 15
and 30 micromolar the compound stop the
cell beating altogether
to quantify the observation in
contractile traces we calculated
cell beating amplitude which is the
surrogate for the force of contraction
as well as the beating rate the y values
in these figures
represent the full change to the time
match control
which means we first calculated the full
change compared to its baseline
and then further calibrated to the
changes of the
of dmso control wells at each time
points
and the 0.2 fold difference from the
baseline was used
as the active or threshold criteria
independent of test concentration
because this magnitude of effect exceeds
baseline variability
so first let's focus on the time course
of beating amplitude
overall ram dan severe induced reduction
in beating amplitude
in the dose and time dependent manner at
72 hours
5 micromolar and benzene started to show
negative
impact on beating amplitude which was
further reduced by 80 percent
at the end of the treatment and the 15
micromolar and 30 micromolar
immediately shut down the cell beating
activity
but interestingly 50 micromolar also
showed a transient
recovery of beating activity from 24
hours
to 48 hours post drug so like
other rtc systems cardio ecr systems
mirrors the cellular events in real time
therefore we won't miss any information
even very transient changes during the
treatment
this also prevents misinterpretation if
you collect the data at the wrong time
points in your endpoint essay
so now let's look at the time course
of the beating rate we can see a very
similar pattern
in the redundancy variant used reduction
of beating rate
shown in this figure
as shown in this 30 seconds contractile
activity
it clearly shows that phi micromolar
cause
irregular beating rhythm so in order to
detect this type of event
automatically and mathematically the bi
beating rhythm irregularity is
introduced to the software
the bi is defined as the coefficient of
variation of beating period
of each individual beats within
this measurement so based on our
empirical data is the bry r
value is about 0.1
that will suggest the irregular beating
rhythm or arrhythmia
so from this time course of bri
we can see 5 micro molar ram densifier
disrupted the cell beating rhythm
after 72 hours post drug
which remained on and off until the end
of the test
so next i want to discuss the impact of
ramadan severe on the electrical
activity of the cells
so these are two representative few
potential signals
obtained before the drug addition the
black trees and 30 minutes after drug
addition
the orange chase this individual
waveforms
within the measurement were further
averaged
into a single waveform and it clearly
shows that
the fp amplitude was significantly
reduced
by ramadan severe at the time course of
mp amplitude also demonstrated that
ramban severe
reduced ip amplitude in the dose
dependent manner
the decrease in fp amplitude may suggest
inhibition
of sodium channel activity however we
cannot ignore that
the cell variability and especially cell
attachment
also play a very important role in the
modulation of ep amplitude
so according to our observation the
reduction of cell attachment
can also reduce fp amplitude
therefore in order to get conclusive
results on
sodium channel activity it's very
critical to monitor the cell attachment
while the fp signal is being measured
and our cardio ucr system does have this
capability
and due to the large variation of
changes in fp amplitude
observed in the long term experiment so
in this talk
i will only focus on the drug effect on
fp amplitude
within the first one hour after
treatment
and indeed the ramadan severe
also those dependently reduce mp
amplitude during the first one
hour treatment without having
significant
impact on the cell attachment as shown
in this overall cell index curve over
here
and as i mentioned ip is another
important parameter
so here we also evaluated
at the field potential duration at 30
minutes post
drug the concentration
at the c-max c-max 5-micromolar and
below had no impact on the
fe signal as shown in these flue bars
however at 15 micromolar and 30
micromolar
they stopped cell functional activity
altogether
no contractile and electrical signals
were detected
so we call this cell crescents so here
we use these two black bars with value
of one
to represent that all replicates tested
at these two concentrations
cause cell crescents
and this is the drug for influenza
treatment
so according to the data collected from
the cardio ecr system
it didn't show significant change in
cell wearability
and contractility including beating
amplitude
beating rate and the beating reason and
there was also
no impact on electrophysiology which was
evaluated by
fp amplitude and fuel potential duration
so overall overall this drug appears to
be safe
in vitro like the
influenza drug this anti-hepatitis c
virus drug seems to be safe in vitro as
well
even while we detected increase in the
beating amplitude
four days post-drug and the reduction of
ip amplitude
from 10 minutes to 30 minutes post drug
these changes are very transient and
also on the border of the threshold
for cardiac active compound
so when you look at the people around
around us you may notice that
more and more individuals these days are
taking multiple
medications which increase the
possibility of drug drug
interaction drug drug inactions poses a
difficult drug safety problem
especially for cardiovascular drugs
there is a long history of drug drug
interaction
some statistical models have been
reported
for predicting potential drug drug
interaction
with electrophysiological effects
however
no individual model has been
demonstrated
so during the our study we also asked
ourselves
what will happen if a patient take
antiviral drug and cardiovascular drug
at the same time and can the cardio ecr
system
together with human ipsc cardiomyocytes
be used for in vitro drug drug
interaction study so in order to
address these questions we recruited two
cardiovascular drugs shown here
they were culturated with the antiviral
drug
respectively so before
we perform drug combination study we
check the cardiac safety profile of
these
two cardiovascular drugs so from these
figures here we can see that
at the tested concentration 0.3
micromolar for a mutual
and 6 micromolar for the saturn they
didn't show
cardiac side effects
so now i'm going to show you the results
on drug combination test
as i have showed you before this hcv
drug alone had
very safe profile it didn't affect cell
variability contractility
and electrophysiology what it
combined with this love sarton it also
appeared to be safe
however when we combined it with a
mutual
it started to show the impact on cell
variability and
attachment demonstrated by the decrease
in the overall cell index also
it affected contractility which is
reflected by the dose-dependent
decrease in beating amplitude while
increase in the beating rate
in addition it showed those dependent
reduction in the fuel potential duration
and this in visual data collected from
cardio ecr system
is comparable to the individual data
so in summary excellence
rtc cardio ucr system has both few
potential electrodes and impedance
electrodes
which provides comprehensive assessment
of
anti-viral drugs and using cardiovcr
system together with human ipicture
cardiomyocytes
we demonstrated that drum density
impacts cell wearability
contractility and electrophysiology
while that influenza drug and hcv
drug show minimum impacts
and this hcv drug which appears to be
safe by itself
does show profound cardio toxicity when
combined with
a mundurum so
with that i would like to conclude my
talk
and thank you very much
uh looks like we might be having an
audio issue
um so i'll go ahead and
[Music]
try and start addressing a couple of the
questions that have been posed
so one question was regarding the
flexibility of the eastside assay
in terms of antiviral drug screening and
characterization
and um so i showed a format where we
we add cells to the plate and allow them
to attach and proliferate
over the the first day and then add
virus and drug
um but variations of that is that you
can use adherent cells
that have just been trypsinized and mix
them with virus
allow that infection to occur in
suspension
and then add that mixture to the to the
plate when you run the assay in that
format
you will get a different impedance
profile the traces look different
but that same that format can also be
used for
um you know identifying what is or is
not an antiviral
and even for uh characterizing in terms
of an ec 50 value
it's also worth noting that um
it's possible to use impedance for cell
types that are not naturally adherent
in order to have an impedance signal the
cells need to interact with the gold
biosensors in an intimate way
and so to facilitate that what we do is
pre-cut the the well bottom with
antibodies
that are specific to a protein on the
surface of those
cells which are not naturally adherent
we've used this approach extensively in
the context of
cancer immunotherapy and work quite well
we actually sell
i think it's five different kits that
allow for this approach to be used
so in the context of virology assays
that that same
that type of approach could uh could
also be used
um yom are we still having audio issues
it seems like we might be so uh why
don't we do this i'll go ahead and uh
and i'll field a couple of
other questions and uh um
[Music]
one for for xiaoyu so are the
contractility
and or electrophysiology measured from
individual cells
thank you brandon so this is actually
when you use the cardio ecr system this
uh we do have two sets of different
electrodes as
i mentioned during my talk so we have
impedance electrode and a few potential
electrodes
the impedance electrodes merit the
average signal from the entire
cell monolayer so not individual cells
for the field potential electrodes we do
have two fuel potential electrodes
but it's still not marrying the
individual cells it's marrying
the cells sit at on top of the few
potential electrodes or
around so but the signal is local
so there are difference between these
two signals impedance
is the average from the entire thermal
cell monolayer
and fuel potential is local information
from the cell culture
yeah thank you so you another question
is um can the cardio ecr
system uh be used for measuring or
or studying cells other than
cardiomyocytes
yes so that's why we call that also
called
rtca right so for as other rtc systems
cardio ucr system also can be used to
measure other cell lines
however i mean that's going to be
overkill because
for the cardio ucr system we have a very
high data acquisition rate which is
um two milliseconds for the entire plate
i think brandon the system you are
talking about it's about
uh maybe 15 seconds for data points
so that very kind of relatively low data
data acquisition rate so that's why the
cardiovr system
mainly used for contractility and but
again it can be used for other cell
lines other than the cardiomyocytes
yeah okay um
great another question regarding esight
is
how many plates can the instrument
accommodate so esight can
accommodate five different 96 well
plates
all five of those plates can be
interrogated using imaging
while three of those plates can be
interrogated using both imaging
and impedance um
another question regarding e-sight is
the the kinetics and what what the
limitation is
so as xiaoyu mentioned for impedance
measurement
you can acquire data from an entire 96
well plate
in about 15 seconds it's actually a
little bit faster than that
so it's possible to do very rapid
kinetics from
an impedance perspective in terms of
imaging
um the fastest i've ever gone is is
about one image per minute i think it
can go
a bit lower than that but um one of the
challenges there is the issue of photo
toxicity
so whether it's eastside or any other
imaging system
the more frequently you're blasting
cells with light the more
problems you're going to have with with
toxicity and that's also very cell type
dependent
so in my hands um i know like i've
imaged uh
a549 cells over the course of multiple
days where i've collected images every
few minutes
and they've done just fine and then with
heck 293 cells
i found them to display much higher
sensitivity to phototoxicity
this also will be dependent on which
which wavelength of light you're using
and what the overall exposure duration
is to that light
each time an image is being acquired so
there's a lot of different factors there
but in
short impedance is non-perturbing
non-toxic
and it can be measured much more rapidly
than uh
is the case with uh images
so um for uh xiaohu another question was
um
uh can the the cardio ecr plates be
reused
yeah we heard about that a lot so no
actually um
especially for cardio ucr plate because
the electric uh
the electrodes they are very very
sensitive i i
already we already know during the
cleaning process
that's going to damage the electrodes
there um couple
reports actually uh from our users they
are saying if you
reuse the plate then you will see a
large
standard deviation during your essay so
we don't recommend you reuse the plate
okay um so another question
uh regarding esight was whether the
assay format would allow for you to
include adsorption and washing steps so
again the assay format is extremely
flexible
so yeah you could imagine having an
adherent cell line already attached into
the
electronic plate bottom and then
allowing an absorption step with virus
that
you know maybe it's you know 20 minutes
or an hour or whatever it may be
and then washing the cells and then
adding in fresh media on top
um absolutely you can um you can do that
with eastside or with any of the
excelligence instruments
um now whether or not that will have an
impact on the impedance signal
will will vary on a case by case basis
so um i showed you an example where the
plate was removed
from the instrument and uh that small
temperature fluctuation during that time
resulted in a
transient uh sort of blip and impedance
you may see something like that but if
the cells are
in the same type of media during the
absorption step
and then after the washing step then in
theory
um the impedance signal should remain
constant there
again temperature may cause a slight
fluctuation but the value should return
to where it was
prior to the wash step um uh
you have to be obviously very very
careful during washing that you don't
dislodge any cells
if you do that that will have a you know
an impact on the impedance signal that
will be lasting
um but in general yeah those types of
things are easily accommodated
a couple more questions here um uh for
show you
do you coat the plate uh prior to
seeding your cardiomyocytes
and then does if you do that does a
codeine impact the
uh impedance uh or the electrical
field potential readings uh thank you
brandon yes we do have a special coding
solution
that's actually just kind of a normal
kind of substrate we
people use for cardiomyocyte which is
fibronectin
and some of our users also like to use
matri gel maybe also
maybe applies to your um experiment but
matrix gel you have to be careful
because the sickness of the
thick not thickness thickness of the
matrix gel is actually
going to affect um the signal collection
yeah great
um so another question regarding esight
is this z prime factor that we mentioned
in terms of quantifying
assay quality for hit detection
and the question is um why
why does that z prime factor differ
when you compare the impedance
trace versus the virus-encoded gfp trace
and um the the reason for this is that
uh it has to do with at the end of the
day
the ability to differentiate between a
positive and negative control
so if i let me back up and say like
let's say that i monitor this process
of the demolition of a building and i
record that
from one mile away using an audio
recording
and then also a video recording you're
watching the exact same physical process
take place but those two types of
recordings
are going to vary slightly in their
their kinetics you know based on how
fast light travels versus how
sound travels and that sort of thing so
with esight when we track
the exact same process this virus
mediated killing
and we do it with impedance and we do it
with imaging
um even though they're looking at the
same thing their inherent sensitivities
and the kinetics that they're detecting
are going to vary a little bit
and what we see is that first they
differ
in magnitude of the z prime factor and
then also
uh the sort of window over which that z
prime factor
uh remains excellent so let's talk about
magnitude
the fact that the magnitude of z prime
is higher
based on an impedance readout than it is
based on an imaging readout
tells us that you can more clearly
distinguish the positive and negative
controls
using impedance than you can using
imaging
and the reason for that is that the
impedance readout is a more information
rich
signal it includes uh changes in cell
number
changes in cell size or morphology and
then also
changes in the strength with which those
cells are interacting with the plate
bottom
and so because you're looking at so many
things together
the ability to detect cells that are
undergoing the cpe
versus ones which are not ends up being
more sensitive than if you're just
tracking how much of that virus-encoded
gfp is around
and then in terms of the duration of
excellence
over which that tool is useful what the
data tells us
is that impedance
remains robust over over a longer window
is
essentially what what the with the data
tells us um i'm kind of struggling a
little bit but um
in short um impedance is just a more
information-rich perspective on what's
going on
um in in terms of uh this this hit
detection
so um with that uh i think that we've
covered all the questions in the queue
and i am back brandon
but obviously you guys were doing
absolutely fine without me so uh so
that's great did i miss anything
the questions in the in the list
i saw those yeah thank you thank you
very much for moderating i had some
technical issues
uh well uh my sincere gratitude to both
you brandon and also
for xavier for sharing your work
and also thanks to our audience for the
questions and
participation thank you very much thank
you
thank you